nobody in hollywood more into fantasy
football than andy holloway one of the
most hollywood guys we know from the
footballers podcast it's great to have
you on man
hey ben appreciate you having me on i
was uh i was all ready to talk fantasy
with you i'm in a good mood and then
you brought up the milwaukee bucks
beating my sons again and i'm a little
flustered now
yeah sons and four guy it's called karma
that's what happened to you andy uh
let's talk some fantasy football though
shall we who's the number one pick in
fantasy this year
his christian mccaffrey i think we're
pretty sure that this year feeling
comfortable with him at number one i
mean uh limited season last year but
he's like two players in one so
i don't think you're going to regret
going him number one
we had uh some questions here in the
studio
perhaps alvin cook in the mix
maybe derek henry is there any idea that
makes sense to go off of christian
mccaffrey at number one
yeah i think you can i mean dalvin cook
has been so
darn reliable and he he represents that
same type of
value and and multi threat that
christian mccaffrey does so if you want
to if you want to head that direction to
make sense henry is henry's tough
because i mean you go up over 2000 yards
but he's he's getting older and he does
not contribute in the passing game the
way that mccaffrey and cook does and
that's just like
cheat code for fantasy football
andy holloway joining the show host of
the fantasy footballers podcast ben
lyons in for rich on the rich eisen show
this time of year when you're watching
preseason as a fantasy footballer are
you taking anything from these games
that you can apply to the season what
are you looking for in the preseason as
a fan
yeah that's a good question because the
more media coverage we get of all this
stuff more
insane levels of hype and coach speak
and extrapolation of
of what you see on three plays happens
and then twitter gets a buzz and
i i even saw i think training camp stats
like stat lines from jimmy garoppolo
versus trey lance this past week so
um
something to tweet about i guess i think
i think the best thing to do is just try
to
uh
not over emphasize one play or another
play but you know last night's game
one of the things that was interesting
to me was like antonio gibson everybody
loves antonio gibson in
fantasy football but he didn't take a
third down snap with the first team you
know jd mckissick was still out there so
i think you just try to pay a little bit
of attention to some of those subtle
things where
can i get a gauge on what this offense
is looking to do
and
try not to overreact you know if a coach
does something bad that's probably
better to pay attention to that than
something good because they all say
something good about their players in
training camp
and try to weed through it a little bit
andy it feels like this summer was the
coronation of tb12 as the goat there
might have been some debates before he
won the
super bowl down in tampa but now
everybody just knows tom brady's the
goat just synonymous and
it doesn't necessarily apply however to
fantasy football what are the
expectations this season of tom brady
fantasy quarterback
well i think he ironically i think he's
probably
the single best pick
at the quarterback position that a
fantasy player can make because
you don't have to invest
a huge
you know high draft pick on him he's an
eighth-round pick right now
in fantasy drafts whereas you have to
spend a second on mahomes or a fourth on
kyler or you pay up for josh allen and
here's tom brady who's just like his
values like suppressed because he's
44 years old so i think he came off the
the super bowl year and all of a sudden
he represents a great value in fantasy
drafts and he ends up on
like tons of our teams here in the
studio
yeah he had 50 touchdowns including the
playoffs last year it's kind of crazy
when you look at that top tier for
quarterbacks like aaron rodgers in my
league i think went in the 12th round
last year that's not going to happen
this year obviously but who who is a
quarterback that you could kind of wait
on and still get incredible value other
than tom brady yeah i think another name
to bring up that's going even later than
brady is ryan tannehill like for
whatever reason
the stink of adam gays has like
permeated through multiple years of
you know tannehill actually producing
for fantasy and
you add julio jones to the mix in
tennessee and that play-action passing
game
and
you can steal tana hill at the back of
draft nobody
wants him on their team for some reason
but year after year in tennessee he's
produced
andy holloway joins the show the fantasy
footballers podcast
let's let's talk some receivers for a
second some of the high profile guys
i find can be a real risk when you're
talking fantasy because if they get
double covered if they get taken out of
the game
they're gonna have those huge stat lines
who are some secondary receivers you
think might emerge my pop that you have
to be aware of as you're constructing
your team
yeah that's definitely a challenge
because you know when you're looking at
the wide receiver position the best
thing you can do is just look at volume
you can't guarantee a guy's going to
have a you know a double-digit touchdown
season outside of maybe you know devonta
adams is in that mix every year tyree
kills in that mix
but you know you had a player like adam
seeland last year who didn't have the
volume you had in years past ends up
with double digit touchdowns but that
could come down because that's such an
unpredictable and not sticky stat i'd be
looking you know when you look at
secondary options i get made fun of on
this show all the time for bringing the
name up
but like aj green is somebody i'm
actually paying attention to
in
fantasy football this year because
you're on a prolific offense in arizona
deandre hopkins uh you know gets double
covered and he's been the the target hog
there and here's aj green in this top
five offense it's just going to be out
there now injury that's been a problem
for him if you want to avoid him i get
it but
i'm i'm glancing aj green's way as kind
of a sneaky really late round pickup
yeah andy i thought we weren't supposed
to ask you about aj
yeah i'm working him in andy holloway
joining the show bending for rich on the
rich eisen show
often times you have to remember that
even if a team is really bad there could
be some really good fantasy players on
that team so which team that we are
expecting to have a poor season might
actually have some good fantasy players
on that team oh man yeah that can be
that can be troubling there's such a
difference between the fantasy value and
the
uh the nfl value on the field i think
you just want to look at teams that are
going to give
a high amount of volume to a certain
player like last year one of the players
that was on a huge amount of league
winning
teams was actually james robinson on
jacksonville a team that won one game
and it was because they handed him the
ball
so many times over the course of the
season so
you know while i'm not staring down the
jets right now as a team that's gonna
offer you a bunch of fantasy value
coming out of the gate but you know a
team like the giants who might not be
expected to be at the very tippy top of
uh the division the nfc east
you know you still have to factor in
saquon barkley there and if they give
him the volume that you would hope for
um you know you look at atlanta like
atlanta was at the basement of the nfc
south but the passing volume for matt
ryan has been so consistent so do you
look at a player like
you know russell gage stepping into the
the target vacuum that julio jones has
left and and you might find some value
there so
you know carolina is another team that's
going to be interesting changing
quarterback and
um you know bringing in
some some weapons on the offensive side
of the ball so
yeah you're looking for volume at that
point as
when you don't have the wins
and andy just reading twitter
is brian edwards really tara owens and
randy moss like what is going on there
can i spend a eighth round pick on this
guy
if if there was a fantasy league that
ran through training camp i think he'd
be on all the like championship teams
it's incredible
he gets high i mean he he dominated the
hype last off season so and what do you
have like 15 catches during the regular
season no i'm not i'm not buying you
know we have a segment on the on the
podcast where we say you know
where there's smoke there's fire that's
all smoke to me in oakland or in las
vegas and so
um yeah i'm gonna wait and see see if
you can do it during the regular season
andy we're talking about teams that are
probably gonna be terrible uh the dallas
cowboys come to mind tj jefferson's team
any star players on that team might uh
might have a fantasy breakout season
what yeah i mean dude you just need back
to play football right i mean last year
it was an incredible start to that
season for him and for the the passing
offense and all the weapons are there
and
like all of that hope gets deleted if
that's not out there on the field so
um i think cd lamb has a monster year if
dak is back i think zeke bounces back to
be an elite
um top tier running back but
kind of important that dak finds his way
out on onto the field
andy holloway joining the show the
fantasy footballers podcast
appreciate you taking some time this
time of year one last bit of advice
for people as they're planning their
drafts they're staying up all night
doing mock drafts till the sun comes up
what's one last piece of advice for
fantasy football teaming uh of team
building yeah
yeah absolutely um i think that first
bit of advice would have been to wait on
quarterbacks so that's like a general
principle but i mean having a plan is
always good like everybody thinks that
it's going to go according to those mock
drafts and everybody's going to
you know follow the uh the consensus but
it never works that way so trying to put
yourself into
the best position to not tilt on draft
day is probably a good idea and being
you know i hear a lot of fantasy players
that
they ask us the question hey do i go
running back running back wide receiver
and we're always saying you know stay
water like
you can't lock yourself into drafting a
certain position at a certain spot or
you're not going to
you know you're going to be tilting from
that point forward when your guy's not
there so have a plan
take a deep breath and um you know have
have fun i mean and don't draft players
that you're not going to enjoy rooting
for either like
you know at the end of the day we're
here to have fun that's what fantasy
football is all about
andy hey this is tj here i just had a
quick question for you um you know
three-time fantasy football champion
here i guess i should that's the proper
way to introduce myself
in the 21 year old league here andy but
normally i've been very good especially
lately picking the right rookie running
back it started with
zeke kareem hunt jonathan taylor i've
got all those guys the rookie years and
they all did very well for me um
got a few guys in mind but tell me who
what rookie are you looking at that you
think that he's going to be the guy this
year
man that's a that's such a good question
we've done a lot of uh of deep diving on
that topic and paid a lot of attention
to like the second and third round
running backs
when they get on the field
they generally out produce the incumbent
so the name that comes to mind is
javonte williams in denver because
over the last what like five or six
years it's like a 75 hit rate where that
guy outperforms the incumbent with
melvin gordon there so
um you know some of the big seasons have
happened due to injury i remember
spencer ware going out in kansas city
that's what gave kareem hunt that big
you know the big upside that season but
yeah i think i'd look javante's way and
then i might look trey thurman's way
late in drafts where you know that kyle
shanahan is going to run the football
and he's going to succeed doing it and
you know raheem mostert is there but
trey thurman may may be uh waiting in
the wings good looking out
andy we appreciate the time good luck in
all of your drafts and i know these guys
will be checking in with you throughout
these throughout the season
yeah sounds good ben thanks for having
me on and uh good luck in your your
drafts as well andy holloway
let's go that time of year fantasy
football the fantasy footballers podcast
andy clearly an expert
on fantasy football hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here